look up in the sky it's a bird it's a
plane it's a majory casting for one of
Netflix's most popular shows keep
watching to find out what other heroic
role was so important that it required
geralt of Rivia to change actors on
Saturday October 29th fans of The
Witcher received news so shocking that
many are already hitting the eject
button on the series altogether Henry
Cavill will no longer be playing our
favorite Gruff monster slaying hero
geralt from season 4 onwards
what is arguably one of the most
lamentable aspects of cavil's departure
is thus not only has he interpreted the
role thus far with commendable
commitment but also the actor's love and
admiration for the World created by
Andre sapkovsky has always inhabited
every aspect of his performance that's
caval that stated in numerous interviews
he was a die-hard fan of first of video
games and then the books and his passion
for the source material and deniably
contributed to him embodying the
character so soulfully according to the
BBC there was a moment years ago when
caval thoughts he had not gotten the
role and he said this left him feeling
in his words crushed however since
becoming geralt Cavill has been
passionately outspoken about his
steadfast dedication to playing the
Whitehead Witcher due to this no one
would have guessed that caval would ever
be willing to pass a role onto someone
else Henry Cavill and geralt of Rivia
seem like a match made in fantasy heaven
so what went wrong well as it may have
become evidence above it is more than
likely that the actor did not just wake
up one day and decide to and his epic
adventure as Garrosh there must be
external factors at work remember in an
interview with The Hollywood Reporter
from November of 2021 caval showed his
gratification for how busy his acting
life had gotten noting all his passion
projects in a way that now feels ominous
in cavill's words after 21 years of hard
work I have three jobs lined up maybe
it's me maybe it's my Approach maybe my
value as a commodity increases being
attached to things like The Witcher now
I can really focus on the storytelling
and grow from here the same interview
saw kaval commit to play Gerald for at
least seven seasons given his passion
for the role what could cause him to
walk away well there's one big blue
suited elephant in the room another
character Cavill is equally passionate
about he was about to consume his time
the much hyped Return of cavil Superman
and Black Adam has everybody talking
arguably the entire future of the DC EU
now rests on caval's Mighty shoulders
and Whispers of a Man of Steel 2 have
grown into a deafening chorus between
that potential sequel as well as a
seemingly inevitable squaring off the
Black Adam and future Justice League
opportunities caval may have simply
reached an impasse for when he was
forced to choose between garos and
Superman unfortunately while both
characters have superpowers caval does
not and perhaps he simply doesn't have
room in his schedule to be both a DC
superhero and the legendary Witcher at
least one factor in this the fact that
Cavill only announced the departure
after geralt had been recast combined
with his deep involvement in production
on The Witcher thus far implies that he
approves of the actor taking his spot
that actor who will be handed the
responsibility of continuing the witch's
Journey will be the brother of Thor
himself Australian actor Liam Hemsworth
in fact Netflix only revealed the
fantasy series was renewed for season 4
the same day Hemsworth was announced as
cavil's replacement one of the brightest
sides of the situation is that Cavill is
not being substituted by a complete
stranger to the world of The Witcher in
an Instagram post Hemsworth revealed to
be delighted at the opportunity Unity to
play geralt as he is also a fan of the
fantasy franchise in his words Henry
Cavill has been an incredible geralt and
I'm honored that he's handing me the
Reigns and allowing me to take up the
white Wolf's blades for the next chapter
of his Adventure Henry I've been a fan
of yours for years and was inspired by
what you brought to this beloved
character I may have some big boots to
fill but I'm truly excited to be
stepping into The Witcher world with
that in mind at least one factor in
Cavill feeling okay about departing a
series he was so passionate about maybe
perhaps that he feels confident in The
Passion of the actor taking his place
with that in mind it still must have not
been easy for Cavill to pass on the role
of the white wolf to another performer
and it may be months or years before the
actor fully opens up about his decision
foreign
[Music]